[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace go to squarespace.com
microcosmos to get a free trial and 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
[Music]
domain when you think of Kombucha you
might think of a nice refreshing healthy
drink one that's exceptionally good for
your microbiome but what we hear at
Journey to the microcosmos think of is
different from that our first thought is
of a Terraria
a place where a whole ecosystem can
exist trapped in
[Music]
glass kombucha is an old and mysterious
drink it's thought to have originated
around 221 BCE in Korea and China though
we had a hard time track tracking down
the sources for that date there are also
reports of Kombucha being consumed in
Russia in the 19th century but those two
time points don't tell us much about how
kombucha came to be and that's not that
unusual when it comes to ancient Foods
here on Journey to the microcosmos we've
ventured into the microbial world of
food like bread yogurt and cheese and
the processes humans have used to make
these foods go so far back and are
accompanied by so much lore that it is
difficult to untangle exact histories
but no matter how murky the history is
the microbial Universe buried in these
Foods is somewhat consistent there is an
organism maybe a yeast or a bacteria or
a fungus it wants to survive and so it
uses the resources around it like sugar
or the proteins and milk to do that it
might even work with one or two other
organisms to accomplish its goals so
James our master of microscopes thought
kombucha was going to be a very familiar
site something chill like brewers yeast
or something like the feeling he gets
when looking at fermentation products
like yogurt under the microscope which
to him are kind of like domesticated
animals in a petting zoo there's a
stable environment and plenty of food
and the organisms within have no
predators and no competitors but that's
not what he saw when he looked at
kombucha the word that came to mind then
was wild it was so wild that at first he
thought he was looking at kombucha that
had maybe gone bad but he quickly
realized that this was not the case
kombucha is just wild like this now if
you know anything about how to make
kombucha then you've probably heard
about this weird thing that James is
pulling out of the top of his kombucha
sample this is the scobby it's a strange
word but it stands for something
symbiotic culture of bacteria and yeast
so yes that Wiggly mass is actually the
weird wild world of bacteria and yeast
that makes Kucha possible we're not in
the business of giving recipes here on
Journey to the microcosmos and besides
everyone has their own preferences so
we're just going to describe how one
might go about making a scobby the
process starts with some brewed tea
usually black or green which is then
mixed with some sugar then a bit of some
prior kombucha is added to the mix
providing a starter culture of the
bacteria and yeast then the container is
covered with something breathable and
set aside over the next few weeks
bubbles begin to form on the surface of
the mixture gathering together until
they form a thin layer that layer
eventually thickens into the solid
scobby while the liquid used in this
fermentation process will ultimately be
too vinegar to drink the scobby can be
used in subsequent fermentations with
brewed tea and sugar
for those of you who are experienced
kombucha Brewers you might be filling in
the gaps of our description with a
myriad of choices that make your
kombucha taste the way it tastes whether
that's the use of store-bought cultures
or the addition of flavorings and later
steps that's the thing about kombucha it
is all so complicated and again
wild the community of bacteria and yeast
that makes up the scobby can vary
tremendously depending on where the
kombucha was originally made
and as fermentation progresses the
composition of the community changes as
well evolving with the culture and
responding to microbes in the air that
might try to interact with the kombucha
so this community we're looking at might
have looked very different a few weeks
prior and the species might not be the
exact same species that make your
favorite kombucha but the underlying
processes they engage in to make that
kombucha are the same when the starter
culture is mixed with the brewed tea and
sugar the yeast use an enzyme called
invertase to break down the sugar into
smaller monomers this kicks off a whole
series of metabolic reactions beginning
with the yeast and bacteria converting
those sugar monomers into ethanol and
carbon dioxide the ethanol could be a
problem as too much can be toxic for the
residence of the mixture luckily the
bacteria are able to oxidize the ethanol
producing acetic acid in the process at
the same time the bacteria makes
cellulose which helps form the biofilm
of the scopy these interactions
demonstrate quite a bit of cooperation
between the bacteria and yeast and each
carries out reactions that make each
other's survival possible they might
break down sugar or lower ethanol levels
or create the molecules that will help
bind the community going forward these
are all examples of cooperation and a
nice found foundation for an ecosystem
for a drink that is as associated with
wholesomeness as kombucha often is as a
nice image but ecosystems aren't marked
solely by cooperation they are also
marked by competition as organisms Vive
for limited resources and space there
are several ways we might see this
competition taking place in Kombucha for
example not all yeast can make invertase
that enzyme that kicks everything off by
breaking down sugar for the community to
partake in these non- invertase yeasts
are considered cheaters taking advantage
of the resources provided by other
organisms without contributing any of
their own but one study of yeast grown
with the bacteria aseria coli found that
cheater yeast tend to not grow as well
as the yeast with invert in an
environment where everyone wants sugar
these cheater yeast don't seem to
survive as well perhaps because their
non-cheating counterparts are able to to
consume a tiny bit of the sugar monomers
they produce and that competition
between yeasts might carry over to the
kombucha earlier we mentioned that
bacteria oxidize ethanol into acetic
acid lowering the pH of the environment
overall this acid is actually one of
several acids found in Kombucha leading
scientists to wonder whether acid in
general serves as a protective quality
of the environment deterring organisms
that can't survive in acidic conditions
and creating a gate against Invaders
that's made out of that low ph and
there's another potential Shield against
Invaders the scobby itself the thickness
of the biofilm acts as a physical
deterrent further strengthened by its
competition which makes it hard for
other organisms to diffuse their way
into the kombucha now we should note
these deterrents aren't always effective
and sometimes unwelcome organisms can
find their way into the scobby at which
point you should probably not drink that
kombucha it is this wild and complex
array of interactions some of which are
better understood than others that makes
us think of Kombucha like a terrarian a
glass bottle full of an environment that
you can watch Brewing itself an
ecosystem with every bit of scobby that
bubbles to the surface and attaches to
each other we get to see this Untamed
landscape assemble and with every scobby
transferred to a new culture we can
replicate this
small wild
[Applause]
Universe thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us and thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
so let's say you're looking to create a
stunning online store for your fashion
brand with Squarespace you can create a
beautiful and professionall looking
website that showcases your Unique Style
and brand and with the help of their
thirdparty extensions you can easily
manage inventory streamlined bookkeeping
and ship products across the world and
if you're interested in blogging about
your fashion brand Squarespace makes it
easy to create a blog that seamlessly
integrates with your online store you
can share your latest collections style
tips and behind the-scenes glimpses into
your creative process with your readers
with Squarespace you can also interact
with your customers and build a
community of fashion enthusiasts through
threaded comments and replies you can
sign up today for a free trial at
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch visit squarespace.com microcosmos
to enjoy a 10% discount on your first
purchase of a website or
domain let's crack open a cold kombucha
to Cheers the people on the screen right
now they are our patreon patrons they're
the people who make it possible for us
to continue exploring all the weird and
wild ways our lives are influenced by
tiny tiny creatures that we barely even
know exist so thank you to our patrons
for allowing us to continue this journey
if you want to joinin them you can go to
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]